want it to be the dino i'll be honest and that's whatever i
don't even care about that all right five seconds we have a
three minute bond
okay uh just ban cap three minute do we ban cap i feel like
elsa mantis is better bands i think so too because i don't
know if i care about the cap too much but
uh what do you think you think so whatever you say captain
yeah i kind of i kind of like that i mean it is their
comfort pick but i also think our comp is pretty good at
dealing with it yeah is there gonna protect cap here maybe
if they don't protect cap i don't think cap does it cap does
too much to uh the tank also especially if i'm on bucky baby
screaming backline yeah we'll see wait the screen last man
could be cap or last man could be um another tank hey last
man cap definitely cap yeah landing cap last and we're
protecting the dinosaur i think which is so odd has
something to play or what i was thinking about my bucky
because uh i mean actually yeah i don't have cats and then
it's just a thing odds gets banned out that's my issue like
what does odds play if the dinosaur gets banned here at the
end yeah yeah sure and i think that's pretty good i said
images like i hate your pc i i wrote i hate your pc i hate
your pc i'll play hud olive on mac odds on dino all right
blank screen game and You're going to see a black screen and
I'll fix it.
I am on duty.
I'll fix it after this game.
I'll play together in general.
I'm just like, they're going to play front to back here.
I had to script.
I doubt they're going to play anything too crazy.
They have their own Bucky for sure.
They might be playing Ultron triple support.
So it's OK.
We can explode their tanks.
I kind of prefer if they're playing triple support here
because then it's really easy for us.
just like blow them up and do some crazy things.
All right, how about this?
I, okay.
Bun line, good bun.
I think that's nice.
My ass, you straddle.
Should we, should we have like a hype up thingy or
something?
Lock in.
You lock in, Olive walk in.
ASMR, rival fling.
Ox lock in.
I'm locked.
Doki, lock in.
Yeah, I'm so locked in right now.
Locked in, okay.
I'm so locked in.
This skin looks so good.
I love that.
I'm not muted, right guys?
You guys hear me?
Are we good?
Yep.
You're good.
Good thing we have Mag.
I just gotta get to this skin.
Yeah, that's good.
Um, I think we just walked on.
Yeah, I guess that comp.
I know what comp they're gonna play, but I assume kind of
like Mag, I think maybe.
I'm gonna take this round here, I think.
So let's see what they're playing.
They're playing Bucky.
i'm shooting him i'm like emma okay we try to terror cape
somebody and just blow them up oh yeah i need them on the
left side uh hubway they are on gambit yeah i want to push
up a bit here back my my my my my my my my my my my i'm
trying to try try push up push up push up oh emma one i
can't yeah i can they're not close enough to terror cape
have you miss the hook
i can terricate this if they push up i have a bubble just
wait for them to push up i bind i blind it blind i blind i
blind Still heals, still heals, still heals.
I'm putting bubble, I put bubble, I put bubble.
Funny, funny, funny.
Funny behind you.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Just live, just live, just live.
Oh, just careful, careful, yours.
I have older than 20.
Nice fucking ghost, by the way.
I have, yeah.
Do you want to farm your old first?
Um, you should farm yours, no farm.
We're gonna get both wolves.
If you look for a hook around this corner, can you just pull
up a little bit with me?
Play here, play here.
We use old first, rocket old first.
Am I pushing here or stay back?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Let me farm then.
92, 94.
When they push us, we rock it out and we blow up somebody.
Okay.
Joe, just heal all of you.
I have it, I have it.
I have it.
I'm good.
I'm placing it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Look in Luna.
Luna's still on Luna.
I'm blinding, I'm blinding.
I blinded.
I got it, I got it.
I got it.
I don't have bubble.
You can belt it.
I'm blinding.
I'm blinding all of them.
I blind all of them.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
I'm blinding, I'm blind, I'm blind, I'm blind, I'm blind.
I'm blind, my, my, my, my, my, my.
Yeah, push, push, push, push, push, push, push.
Yeah, I'm on the right.
Yeah, I'm on the right side.
You're portaling, portaling, portaling, portaling,
portaling.
Okay, what about?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get ready for the portal, blow.
They might grab somebody.
Or you can play high ground here.
Or actually, just play in the back here.
Yeah, I'm playing here.
I'm playing, I'm playing.
i can i'm looking for a blind yep i'm gonna hold this i
blind the luna blind the luna
i got luna i got drew this or it's cute yeah i helped you
yeah i helped no more no no no no it's we win this i'm
biting my needle pulling him back nice
what's up guys uh our economy is a little bit bad we need to
play slow next um i don't think they have much they
shouldn't have they used emma they used mag uh they used
both of wardo's but they're close to luna yeah don't waste
maybe i don't think she's gonna staggered and died we're
gonna have we're gonna have rocket before they have luna
yeah i can i can i'll let you yeah i'll let you build Okay.
Play slow and go under, I think.
And just build up the Rocket Oak and then we, or do we just
go main?
We could go main against Elkhorn.
We don't have to go under.
They're not playing that.
Just go main, farm your Rocket Oak and send it.
And we are going to change, do you think they're going to
change strategy seeing that they, that they struggled?
No.
Guys, this is like the, it's like, it's like we're, we're
Daredevil right now, guys.
It's like, this is how he lives his life.
We're being immersed.
We're immersed.
ourselves into rivals it's just immersion guys okay just
play here until point lost there'll be 50 on you I'll let
you build I'll let you build yeah yeah sorry sorry sorry I
oh can you go back up the stairs we can kill the wolf that's
good Thank you guys.
I'm trying to help you.
Just for that.
I'll be.
Good one.
Hold on.
I have to use both my...
Walk mine and play walls.
Or just little air spells.
Sorry guys.
You can rock it all.
It's okay.
Look at those.
No, no, no, no.
I don't have it.
I'm blinded but I don't think we live that.
I'll have it.
I'll have it next.
Oh, um, we have it.
We group.
It's fine.
Just this.
They're gonna, I don't think they use plenty, right?
They should have plenty, but should.
Yeah, they should still have honey.
They'll be close.
I think we need to shoot that.
We need to shoot that because it's going to burn on rocket
ult really fast.
We need to shoot that and you need to play more passive
loss.
Don't drop.
I just don't understand the geometry of the map.
It's a while, but I will follow.
I will follow.
We have all here.
Shoot them, shoot them, shoot them.
Don't be scared.
Push up.
You're low-age people.
I can maybe, I can build my own.
I ulted, I ulted, I ulted.
I ulted, I blinded.
I'm shooting him.
But we can't win this fight.
I'm weak hiding.
Okay.
Yeah, I had to That's fine Can we get somebody here?
I got I got oh, this is really good.
That's good.
I got the wolf Just die die die die.
This is so good for us good Just move down both support
those bunio down.
They are gonna have all of they're gonna have Oh, so I know
if you want to save yeah, I'll probably save it for that.
I have we do still have to melt it though They have Mago.
They have Mago, okay?
All if you can come back to me or go save.
Yeah, I might have to come back.
That's three, two, one, pushing in, okay?
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk,
walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
I got one.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
He's looking for you.
Play with me.
I'm definitely, I'm ready.
Oh, I thought you got res here.
I'm ready.
Oh, you're ready.
Nice.
No more, no more, no more.
We win this.
I'm on, I'm on.
We just killed him.
I'm trying to kill him.
Ke op kiel kill kill kill kill kill kill him.
I have wolf on me.
Wolf wolf wolf wolf full full full full right side right
side.
Nice.
Good for us good for us.
Do we place one or do we just play point?
I'm gonna let you build all the things.
Oh, oh, I misclicked.
Okay.
Oh, oh good.
Oh, good.
Landed landed landed landed big boomer clap.
Oh I don't worry.
I don't worry about it.
69% We didn't need that Oath.
Do I use my ult here the moment they push?
Oh,
I have ulti on point.
I have another one.
Jubilee down.
No kill.
I have ulti on point.
No killers.
I have blind.
I'm blind.
I'm blinding him.
Left side, uh, left side.
Huge win, huge win, huge win.
We need to push up.
I have 62.
No, no, no, no, they have Luna.
They have Luna.
Doki can farm.
I need a farm.
I need to take damage.
Yeah, Doki just heal.
Just heal a lot.
Hold on.
Just farm mode, farm mode.
I have Reson 76.
80.
I need you guys to do.
Yeah.
They have no wall ball.
91, 91, 91.
Just keep.
We almost have...
99, 99!
I got it!
I'm on point though.
I did it on point, I did on point.
I did on point.
I'm shooting punny.
I have ult.
Live, live, live, live.
I'm blinded, I blinded.
You're good, you're good.
Keep him alive.
Trying, trying, trying.
I'm holding this.
I'm holding this for you.
I'll take this for you.
So look if it kills.
I'm dead.
He's looking for it, he's looking for it.
He's looking for it.
Hood behind.
They're low, low, low.
Blinded, blinded, blinded, blinded, blinded, blinded.
Hood won, Hood won.
Oh, Hood was so low.
He lives, he lives, he lives, he lives, he lives.
We have to die on point and TP.
Live, live, live, live, live.
We can live.
We can live, we can live, we can live, we can live, we can
live, we can live, we live, we live.
Just keep it, just keep it.
I couldn't.
I think we're TPing here.
You have to.
I have TP coming back.
TP, TP, TP.
Oh, nearly ready?
Or nearly ready?
I'm doing it coastside.
Oh, nice touch.
Touch now.
Be in touch.
We'll look and grab on you.
I think we're dead.
That's all I got.
Someone else is going to do this.
Loose this, lose this, lose this.
I don't think we're running this.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's good.
Cool.
I think next we play with Rocket and Dinosaur.
I don't know if they have any support though, so be honest.
I think we win this pretty straight forward.
They use Jubilee ult, so...
Yeah, they use Jirio.
His funny swap to TP, so he's not going to have funny ult.
Yeah, they shouldn't have much.
Okay.
So just play point, play with Rocket Oak.
We can Dino it as well.
It's whatever.
My ult will be ready in first fight.
Do you guys have any point that's going to drop?
Yeah, yeah.
We can just Rocket Oak and you can use the ult and you can
just like go crazy.
I don't think they have anything.
I'll try to call the tempo.
Okay.
Doki, do you know where I might place Rocket Oak?
I mean, you can place it on the high ground thing.
Say before after.
He's a high girl or like Okay, I mean it's don't think too
much about you just send it and we just send it with it
We're sending it then you just does anyone else's ping
crazy?
I mean, I have 130 permanent.
I have a thousand ping right now.
Well, okay.
That's a bit crazy.
Oh, that's you're not supposed to get a thousand Sure.
Is it is a constant thousand?
It's 734 now and I see Doki just walking forward.
I mean nobody else.
Oh, you should pop Yeah, you're not moving.
We need a pause, we need a pause.
I didn't think...
I can try resetting my modem router.
Or... I don't know.
I'm really sorry.
Let me restart my game.
It's okay.
I'm hearing storms in my place, so if I suddenly disappear,
lightning struggle, guys.
She's getting doxxed right now.
The gods are trying to smite us, bro.
yeah oh this is awful dude sorry for those who are wondering
why we're at black screen i didn't have time to test
anything because i woke up had to scrim and then distance
for like 10 minutes i think we should just walk right side
no i have to i don't have time i had to fix it on hello just
so you know i'm here um so i see that you requested a pause
uh you said that uh yuchi is having a thousand yeah i have a
thousand i had a thousand ping and it was oscillating from
like anywhere from 300 to 1,000.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Is there any?
I'm trying to restart my game.
And if that doesn't fix it, then I can try resetting my
modem router.
Go ahead and just restart.
No, you're fine.
Things happen.
If anything, just go ahead and try to restart your game and
let's see if it makes it any better.
If we'll just go one step at a time.
OK, maybe I do have time.
I'll be back momentarily just to check on you with that.
Let me just make sure that I tell my admin.
Okay, I think it's better.
I'm at 74 again.
So sorry, were you saying something?
I didn't mean to cut you off.
I think it's better.
I'm back in.
Yeah, she's saying it's better now.
Okay, all right.
I'll go ahead and initiate the continue then.
So sorry.
Are you back in game?
Were you lagging last round, or was it just this round?
No, it was just the beginning of this turn.
I wasn't lagging the last game.
Yeah, it looks like we're starting now.
All right.
Well, the admin has to press start.
We're going to walk, I think, right side.
We need to wait.
No, we're going to look to...
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Don't go anywhere, guys.
I have all...
What are we doing?
Push-ups to drag around.
Yeah, yeah.
Go main with rocket old or do you want to go main go main go
main?
Go main.
Oh, come.
Send it.
Push, push, push, push.
Push, push.
I'm blinding again.
I'm grabbed.
We win this.
You win this.
No more.
Yeah.
I'm giving you guys bubble.
Give me guys bubble.
No more.
Just like we were in.
Top shelf.
Above us.
Yeah.
That's fine.
There's manning.
Come on.
is this 82 i'm i need a place uh res for one let's farm
close what's my place to wait out guys up here with you guys
just always play with us yeah we play hard here up here
they're kind of walking main though they're walking away i
can't drop uh you guys are lagging for me yeah yeah watch
out wolf watch out wolf you're rocking an orally oh we might
deposit we need a pause sorry i'm just gonna reset my load
and that's okay that's okay i don't know if we can pause
mid-fighting oh they're pausing yeah usually they won't let
you pause mid-fight so that was uh that's not your fault
though that's that's the admins if they're okay with that
then they're okay with uh hello again i'm so sorry i'm just
gonna reset my modem router i i think i'm just having
internet difficulties i'm really sorry i'll leave now oh
he's restarting not leaving
yeah um give me one second because there's two things that
could possibly happen we'll have to see when she gets her
run back but we don't want to take the match too long
obviously this isn't is it is it are you live streaming like
is do you think the live stream is messing with it if you're
live streaming uh well if she's streaming then it probably
would take more stuff on it but she may have to stop her i
don't think she was when she's restarting yeah
if anything if she's still having issues we might just have
to play out this fight play out this fight and just see how
it goes and of course i would hate to have to sub someone
some someone in rosie considering it's kind of out of her
control but i mean of course that would be up to you guys as
a team but we do have subs on standby in the event that she
cannot play due to her internet issues all right thank you
that's where it going no problem um but i will be back
really shortly let me go ahead and just let my admins know
that this is being an issue all right i have time okay guys
i'm gonna fix my stream again i think if you're around to i
think it's because like the obs is not an admin mode i think
that's why okay guys i'll be right back again i'll be right
back